notre gouvernement va lancer des
consultations en octobre 2022
Ottawa veut explorer de nouvelles idées
pour réformer la loi sur la non
divulgation du statut sérologique au
pays l'objectif moderniser le système de
justice canadien comme le souhaite des
groupes de miltes qui réclament que l'on
cesse de criminaliser des personnes
vivant avec le VIH essentiellement une
personne doit divulguer son statut dès
lors qu'il existe une possibilité
réaliste de transmission du VIH lors de
rapport sexuel le grand problème qu'on a
c'est que il y a pas une définition
précise de ce qui est une possibilité
réaliste de transmission depuis 1989 le
réseau juridique VIH compte plus de 200
personnes de séropositives qui ont été
accusés pour ne pas avoir partagé leur
statut les accusations qui peuvent être
portées en lien avec ça sont
accessiblement grave on parle
d'agression sexuelle grave de casser les
silos c'est un peu le docteur
Jean-Pierre routier déplore que les lois
actuels criminalise les personnes vivant
avec le VIH même dans des cas où la
possibilité de transmission est faible
voire inexistante si la personne est
bien traitée il n'y a pas de risque de
transmission et donc la loi doit changer
la crimination ne correspond pas aux
données de la science selon lui la
criminalisation a de lourdes
répercussions sur la vie des personnes
vivant avec le virus je suis impliqué
dans plusieurs procès comme expert et ce
qui est étonnant c'est que la personne
qui porte plainte n'est pas infectée
mais elle porte plaine souvent dans des
moments de de divorce de séparation
juste pour embêter l'ancien partenaire
et alors qu'elle n'est pas infectée le
simple fait de l'avoir exposé au risque
est suffisant et ça c'est une des
problématiques qui est souvent dénonciée
ça doit être au loin c'est trop exagéré
c'est mieux c'est une maladie c'est une
maladie dans le village gay de Montréal
plusieurs estiment que les lois
actuelles vont trop loin là-dessus
on devrait être population je pense
qu'au départ c'est le respect avec la
personne surtout s'il y a des risques
pour la santé de l'autre personne les
consultations prévues cet automne
permettront du moins d'apporter un peu
de clarté au débat qui viseront à
recueillir la vie des intervenants et du
public sur la meilleure façon de
moderniser la réponse du système de
justice pénale dans le monde environ 1.5
millions de nouvelles infections VIH ont
été rapportées en 2021 soit plus de 4000
personnes par jour ici ldsin
Radio-Canada Montréal